Bonjour bonjour ! *attention dans 3..*
mmmmdrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrrr
Aujourd'hui c'est l'heure de la vidéo... NOSTALGIE. *2..*
*1..*
NOS
TAL
GIIIIIIIEEE *mes oreilles help*
Voilà.
Petite blague que j'me réservais de
faire au moment
où
on commençait à faire cette vidéo!
Aujourd'hui les amis on va voir
par quoi on a commencé
Ou d'où l'on vient
Quelles sont nos racines ?
iiiooolllloo
Quelles sont...............
NOS ORIGINES
Car il ne faut pas les renier !
Il faut les assumer..
Pff...
Qu'est-ce que j'raconte ?
C'est vrai qu'avant d'faire des vidéos
Comme c'qu'on fait aujourd'hui
On faisait des vidéos
Eeeeeeeeeeuh
eeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeeehhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhhh
Un p'tit peu expérimentales !  (ouloulou)
Un p'tit peu moins fou
ET JE SAIS QU'ON A DEJA FAIT UNE VIDEO
COMME CELLE-CI
Eeeeeeuh
... Y'A UN AN OU DEUX..
Ou je sais plus, mais
J'avais envie d'le refaire et d'expliquer un p'tit peu plus
..c'qui s'passait à l'époque dans ma tête.
Donc, tout a commencé par une vidéo
de qualité extraordinaire vraiment !
Les gens ont RT, ils se sont abonnés..
Ils ont FAV à l'époque ! (*-* C'EST FAUX)
AH! AVEC CETTE INTRO..
Y'a du..  j'ai du son?
D'ACCORD
Donc avec cette merveilleuse intro SAN SON !
Qui a dû feinter des centaines de personnes
*son du jeu Crysis 2*
*Voix de SQUEEZIE * Salut à tous et à toutes, donc c'est SQUEEZIE, on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour *coupure*
TA GUEULE.
2011!  Vous êtes beaucoup à connaître cette vidéo , c'est là que j'avais décidé de faire une vidéo
Heu pas forcément humoristique à l'époque à l'époque j'voulais plus faire des vidéos sérieuses sur les jeux  vidéos
Et donc j'avais une sorte de vidéo "test" sur le multi de Crysis 2 j'avais mis une correction des couleurs de FILS DE PUTE
Et donc j'avais une sorte de vidéo "test" sur la démo de Crysis 2 j'avais mis une correction des couleurs de FILS DE PUTE
Pour faire genre queeeeee
C'était beau ;-;
*voix SQUEEZIE * Donc eeeeuuuh
La démo est téléchargeableeeuuuhh sur Steam gratuitement hein, donc vous allez dans le magasin, vous tapez Cry- *Re-Coupure*
Putain
J'sais pas si vous arrivez à sentir mais je suis pas DU TOUT serein
Je me PISSE dessus au moment où j'fais cette vidéo c'est extraordinaire
Bref on a commencé par ça
On f'sait donc beaucoup de Call of Duty hein comme 100% des putains de YouTubers euh à  l'époque
*En lisant* : TUTO comment faire des 360 sur PC ?
J'ai fait ça moi ?
Moi le mec qui savait le MOINS faire ça au MONDE j'ai fait un tuto pour apprendre à le faire??
Voilà j'me cherchais clairement j'étais en en pleine recherche d'identité
Et j'me souviens qu'à l'époque j'regardais un YouTuber qui s'appellait... BeastMode3.
C'était un gars qui vivait au Québec, et qui faisait des vidéos sur les jeux vidéos mais en mode drôle, détente...
Et il avait la tchatche et ça me plaisait ÉNORMÉMENT
Et il  avait la tchatche et ça me plaisait ENORMEMENT
Donc j'ai décidé de suivre un p'tit peu sa voie et m'orienter un peu plus vers le fun
C'est là que bon nombre d'entre vous  m'avez peut-être connu
Devant les "Défis de Squeezie"
Voilà , Où je jouais et à chaque
Putaiiiiiin là *respire*
LA JEUNESSSSSSSE !
On vient de loin putain c'est ouf
Donc là le but c'tait d'prendre du ta-du tabasco à chaque mort
Et ce qui est marrant
C'est que des ANNÉES après ce truc est revenu à la mode
Et y'a des gens qui ont refait des vidéos où euh...Pas sur Call Of Duty mais sur d'autres jeux-
où dès qu'ils mourraient ou quoi y'avait- y'avait un truc à faire
Et nous on a  commencé par ça PUTAIN
C'est ça qui est beau *malaise dans 3..*
OOOOOOH *2..*
Notre config' de l'époque les gars ! *1..*
*Voix de squeezie * Salut tout le monde les guys
C'est SQUEEZIE, *râle* alors écoutez aujourd'hui je fais cette petite vidéo parce que
*Voix de SQUEEZIE * Vous êtes vraiment beaucoup à me demander *coupure*
Mais la jeunessssse
La peau lisse
Sans imperfections parce que j'venais d'f- de terminer un traitement au cure- acnée !
Le traitement bien hardcore sa mère qui te dessèche les naseaux mais qui te retire tous tes boutons d'acné
*re-voix de SQUEEZIE* Euh... UM30
Wooooooooooooooooooooooooh *rire*
Gros setup en vue !
*Voix de SQUEEZIE* Je vous conseille de prendre une 500 watts hein... ou une 550 parce que ça vaut l'coup
*Toujours Voix de SQUEEZIE* Parce que sinon, vos composants sont un peu sous-alimentés
'tain, j'étais le PRO
Pour répéter c'que j'avais lu 10 min avant
Et qui si ça se trouve étaient totalement FAUX
J'étais un putain d'escroc
*musique *
*Voix de SQUEEZIE* Regardez bien les basses messieurs dames, regardez bien! *tuez-moi svp*
*Voix du Squeezie Puceau* Regardez bien les bases messieurs, dames! Regardez bien!
*Malaise*
*Musique *
*Rire*
C'est dégueulasse le son !
Qu'est-ce qui m'avait pris à l'époque ?!!!
*enjaillement du puceau*
*10/10*
*on s'amuse*
Ahh c'est malaisaaaaant
DE OUUUUUUUUUUUUUF
AAAAAAAAHHHHHHHH!!!!!
M'en bat les couille j'fais un portail dans le temps là, comme dans Dr.Strange. (nom de film)
Je vais prévenir le Lucas d'avant de pas faire ça *GOO !*
*Enjaillement *
*Enjaillement certain*
Arrêtons nos conneries, je vais réveiller tout les voisins euhhhhhhhh...
*Squeezie Puceau* Arrêtons les conneries, je vais réveiller tout les voisins...
Tu habites dans une maison .
Il est 16h
Tu ne vas réveiller personne ;w;
Tu ne vas réveiller personne
Ne cherche PAS d'excuses jeune puceau.....
faisons le point mes projetkjuion mais c'est quoi  ces vidéos là ? T.T
faisons le point mes projets... Mais c'est quoi ces vidéos là?
Ah et la p'tite intro à base de 3D que tout le monde avait
C'était la mode hein ! *pas vraiment*
Eh bien, salut tout le monnnnde, c'est SQUEEZIE et si on s'retrouve aujourd'hui avec ce short de bain sur la tête
C'est pour... *rires* c'est ridicule, j'avais envie de faire ça
Attends, j'me recoiffe, parce que je suis un beau gosse *EW* nan j'déc...
*MALAISE*
*ow shit*
*respire zizie*
*ça va aller*
*Souffle*
*rires*
*Voix de puceau* Alors écoutez, j'avais envie de faire le point, euh... à propos des vidéos à venir et des idées que j'ai eu. Alors, euh... *coupure*
Attends mais on dirait qu'j'passe mon oral de français
On a jamais vu moins naturel devant une caméra
Bon voilà en gros dans cette vidéo j'dis qu'jai des idées en fait j'en ai pas eues et j'demande aux gens de me proposer des idées dans les commentaires
Le grand classique du YouTuber fumé
BREEEEF
On zappe cette phase malaisante de Call Of Duty et de
Je me... cherche ;-;
Je me cherche
On arrive ensuite à la Paris Games Week de 2011
Putain mon gars c'est vieux de ouf
J'y étais allé j'avais vu des YouTubers j'avais croisé M.V12
J'y étais allé et j'ai vu des YouTubers j'ai croisé Mr.V12 escorté par une euuu babe du salon
Escorté par une euuuhhh...
...Babe du salon.
Voilà
Mr.V12 c'est gratuit
C'est pour toi
Et ensuite on atteint les 10k abonnés
C'est incroyable et 10k abonnés c'est l'occasion d'faire quoi ? De faire mon PREMIER podcast !
C'est incroyable 10 000 abonnés c'est l'occasion de faire quoi ? De faire mon PREMIER podcast !
Et j'avais essayé de le faire sur les toilettes
Voilà c'qui reflétait bien ma maturité à l'époque finalement
Bon récemment on a fait le KAKASUTRA
Qui est la pire vidéo de ma chaîne YouTube de tous les temps
On a pas tant changé qu'ça finalement
*Puceau* Yo tout le monde, c'est SQUEEZIE *le même que maintenant dit de la même façon*
Il était là
Le "Yo Tout le monde c'est Squeezie" était déja là !
En 2011
*voix de squeezie puceau* On s'retrouve aujourd'hui pour mon tout premier PODCAST *ouéééé*
AIIIII !!!!
Oh, la racaille !
Qui a dit que j'était une racaille?
*oh god*
*oh hell nawwAaaAWWw*
*cringe*
*pars, abrège mes souffrances*
Pff... tapette
*rire forcé*
*Rires malsaints* NOPE
Ce n'est pas validé par la prod(uction) mais c'est mignon tout plein !
*Puceau* Non mais il y a rien à dire, franchement les toilettes, c'est LE SEUL endroit AU MONDE
Où t'es TRANQUILLE, quoi !
'Fin, quand je dit "c'est (le seul) endroit au monde où t'es tranquille"
Euh... presque!
Presque.
OUI, DÉSOLÉ, PRESQUE!
J'arrête pas de taper eeeeuh sur ma cuisse avec mes mains j'ai un problème
BREF
Bon voilà j'pense qu'en... en 30 secondes on a vu le taux de  malaisitude assez élevé
Mais voilà j'voulais tenter... euh... ces fameux sketchs et j'en ai fait jusqu'à d'ailleurs j'crois mon dernier c'était celui-là et c'était quand même eeeen 2013
Il y a trois ans donc finalement
J'aurais tenté pendant longtemps
de percer là-dedans
Ohhh j'ai du faire un truc trop malaisant c'est une vidéo sur le Trailer d'MW3 j'ai remplacé tous les sons par des
...bruits de ma bouche ;-; [why?]
Les bruits de ma bouche.
*Narrateur* Mais bientôt, vous verrez
*Squeezie de l'époque qui essaye d'imiter le narrateur* Que chaque son
*Toujours SQUEEZIE* Chaque voix
*Narrateur* Etait destiné
*Toujours Squeezie* A te faire rigoler!
*Le malaise est présent*
C'est un supplice
MAIS NAAAAAAAAAAAAAAN
Mais putain j'avais quoi j'avais 15 ans du coup
Putaiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiin
*Le malaise continue...*
J'vais m'arrêter euh à cette vidéo voilà vous irez la voir par vous-même
J'préfère m'arrêter euh à cette vidéo voilà vous irez la voir par vous-même
Vous rejoignerez les 111 000 personnes qui on passé un très mauvais moment devant.
Là on se cherche encore on sait pas trop quoi faire
On continue "Les défis de SQUEEZIE",
On fait du Battlefield et différents jeux
Et c'est là que me viens une idée , j'me dis et si au début d'mes vidéos gaming , j'faisait une petite intro de type podcast de 1 min
Parce que je suis pas assez bon pour faire des vidéos entières de podcasts donc je vais faire
un mini podcast au début d'mes vidéos gaming
Par exemple sur le mode 1 balle chargée de COD BO à l'époque
*Squeezie Puceau* GARDE A VOUS, SOLDATS !!
*rires malaisants de Squeezie d'à l'époque*
Ah la loose !!!
TOI, FERME TA GUEULE!
MON UNIFORME ETAIT AU SALE, ET MA GRAND-MERE M'A DONNE CE SWEAT POUR LE REMPLACER!!!
*Rires ENCORE malaisants*Ah la loose !!
J'AI DIT "FERME TA GUEULE" ! BON *coupure*
C'est dur hein xD
franchement c'est dur
de regarder ces images
Eh mais heureusement malaiseTV n'existait pas à l'époque !
Mais il m'aurait mis direct  sur sa chaîne mon gars
ma carrière elle aurait été finie !
Jour 1!
Mais ça montre que quand tu commences tu fais pas du tout des trucs ouf
Surtout quand t'es jeune
T'as une vision des choses un peu différente
Et quand tu vieillis et que tu mûris  et que tu prends du recul tu t'aperçois que tu faisais vraiment des trucs bidons
Mais j'suis content d'avoir fait ça parce que j'ai expérimenté des trucs
Et j'trouve que c'est bien d'expérimenter des choses
Et d'ailleurs si vous êtes YouTuber j'vous souhaite d'expérimenter des choses
Bon je vous laisse ces petites intros humoristiques quiiii...
qui était du coup très drôle comme vous pouvez le voir.. HO NAN encore un HO NAN
encore un podcast sur
les PROFS
*voix de puceau* ...tu découvres ton nouvel emploi du temps et tes nouveaux profs.. euh... en plus de ça,
Tu découvres aussi les gens dans ta classe... euh.. d'ailleurs qui sont parfois plutôt bizzares
*Puceau* Excusez moi les mecs c'est ici la 1ere S3 ou pas en fait ? J'en sais rien moi, laisse moi rouler mon tard-pé YEAH YEAH YEAH YEAH
Eh tu veux du shit mon frère ? S'tu veux j'en ai plein hein ! Quoi t'en veux pas quoi Walah D'où tu m'agresses comme ça FILS DE PRRRR !!!
Salut toi! Ca va bien?
On fait un chat-bite ?
*soupir*
c'est dur..C'est dur..Mais *rire*
Mais il faut qu'on s'inflige ça c'est nos racines BORDEL !
C'est de la d'où on vient !
On continue les podcast
Ha j'avais déja fait un truc sur le plagiat à l'époque en 2012
*voix de puceau* Alors, c'que j'adore dans les gens qui traitent de plagieur, c'est que généralement...
Ils traitent les gens de plagieurs POUR RIEN
Autant, si tu fais quelque chose qui ressemble TRES fortement à ce que quelqu'un d'Entre Guillemets connu,
à fait, là c'est du plagiat d'accord *coupure*
Attend c'est super glauque cette vidéo ya des *rire*
parce que je me met a la place du mec qui regarde
Y a juste des photos de meufs en maillot et tout
heuuu collé au mur derrière moi. #Pervers
On dirrai un mec qui prend des photos en cachette
de filles et qui les scotche comme ça sur ses murs dans sa chambre...
En vrai c'est mes demi-soeurs hein arrêtez tout de suite de m'accuser
de quoi que ce soit hein
'Fin.. C'EST LA CHAMBRE de mes demi soeur
NAN C'est pas moi qui ai fantasmé
Donc comme je disais donc.. ces putain de.. de podcast on a atteint les 50.000 abonnés
On est très heureux toujours puceau, mais très heureux
On continue les vidéos gaming et à partir de là donc c'était vraiment en 2013
Quand à l'époque j'avais emménagé , j’habitais à "Anthony" j'avais emménagé à "Place d'Italie"
J'étais toujours chez mes parents et c’est là-bas que je faisais vraiment des vidéos sur le même principe de ce qu'on fait maintenant
C'est-à-dire ben juste jouer à un jeu vidéo
Faire des cuts, faire des changements de plans, rajouter des effets et des trucs
Mais j'étais quand-même beaucoup moins naturel que maintenant, etttt...
Eh bah c'était différent, j'étais plus jeune ! MAIS,
En vrai, C'EST LA qu'on a commencé à faire ce qu'on fait encore MAINTENANT!
*Puceau* Voilà, ah bah non ça marche pas, du coup, je choisis de m'en aller *rires*
La grosse tapette.
Alors ce soir, on assiste à un ring qui ne sert à rien, voilà,
Dans le ring, on peut observer une poule *bruit d'oiseau*
Bon voilà, j'avais, euh... En fait, j'avais moins d'improvisation, j'arrivais moins à improviser donc...
euh.. je comblait par PLEIN D'EFFETS AU MONTAGE
Et puis j'avais fait mon PREMIER "Question Time"
Vers ici,
Oui, absolument!
Une F.A.Q un p'tit peu humoristique ça vous avez MEGA plu, d'ailleurs on en avait fait au total 13 ou 14, je sais plus, ça avait complètement cartoné
A partir de mai 2013, on était vraiment dans ce qu'on fait maintenant. L'arrivée de l'Oculus DK 1
Le Development Kit 1, c'est une version trop pourrie de l'Oculus qui était horrible et.. à la fin de chaque vidéo que je faisait avec ce truc,
J'avais la nausée DE MALADE
Je faisait un vrai malaise, pendant 30 minutes j'était tout blanc allongé sur mon lit, et j'me disait.. :
Putain c'est bon, j'ai fait ma vidéo avec l'Oculus, ça va faire des vues, je pense qu'à l'argent.Voilà
*rires*
Puis on a continué, continué, continué
Ensuite il y a eu Cyprien Gaming à ce moment là qui a ouvert aussi
Regardez Cyprien Gaming, la première vidéo Cyprien Gaming
C'est incroyable
La dernière fois j'ai croisé un mec
Et donc sur Cyprien Gaming on avait refait ce délire d'intro, un petit peu sketch
avant la vidéo gaming.
Il a appelé la chaîne Squeezie Gaming, CY-PRI-EN GAMING !!
NON mais franchement c'est nul !
Ils sont fous les gens !
Heu Squeezie, tu sais que tu parles à une statue depuis tout à l'heure.
Tu le sais ça ...
Ouais, ouais. Je sais ouais. Ouais
Putain, j'avais toujours un don d'acteur incroyable.
Cyprien, merci de m'avoir pris.
Parce que, j'étais vraiment pas très bon.
*rires*
Hey bah voilà ! Du coup, j'étais super content que Cyprien me contacte pour faire cette chaîne secondaire.
En fait, je passais beaucoup de temps seul devant mon PC à faire des vidéos sur ma chaîne
A faire le montage pendant 6 heures, à être seul comme ça devant son PC chez toi.
Puis être tout le temps chez toi aussi, mine de rien, jamais trop sortir
Et donc, Cyprien Gaming ça m'a fait vachement de biens parce que finalement c'était la même chose que
ce que je faisais mais à 2 et c'est pas moi qui faisais le montage.
En plus c'était John, du coup le cadreur-monteur de Cyprien Gaming.
C'était vraiment trop marrant et j'étais dégoûté parce que j'avais pas pu aller à l'E3.
Parce que j'étais en train de passer mon putain de bac que j'ai eu !
13,8 ! 13,8 !!!
Bon à coté il y a Kévin du Rire Jaune qui a son diplôme d'ingénieur. Mais bon.
Un peu de respect pour les grosses merdes Kévin s'il te plaît.
Sur toutes ces vidéos là on est en 2014 et je pense qu'à partir de là il y a pas grand chose à dire
parce que finalement c'est comme ce qu'on faisait maintenant.
Bon même si maintenant on a, on a muri, grandi, la barbe et tout ça.
L'humour est différent d'avant mais ouais je sais pas, j'ai pas de sens à dire tout ça.
Parce que j'ai l'impression que c'était vraiment hier quoi
que je faisais ces vidéos là
alors que c'était il y a déjà deux putains d'années.
Oui regardez, elle est là la vidéo qu'on avait, la vidéo comme ça qu'on avait déjà faites.
Mais il y a un an et demi.
Passe moi le chromi, j'utilise plus de données chromi.
Les vidéos sur LoL comme Siri
Ah !!!!!!! (avec musique)
*rires*
J'étais déjà mort devant le malaise à l'époque
Voilà, je crois qu'on a fait le tour les amis.
Écoutez, je suis tout ému
Non, sans déconner je suis vraiment ému de revoir tout ça.
En fait de le revoir, tout simplement, tout le chemin qu'on a parcouru
Parce que, tu sais, on est tout le temps rush, je trouve, dans le quotidien
dans faut avancer, faut avancer, faut faire des trucs
et on oublie ce qu'on a fait avant.
Je suis tout ému, ça me rappelle plein de bons souvenirs
Même la phase où je fais des trucs de merde
où je me cherchais, où je voyais que j'avais envie de faire
dans l'internet, de vivre de ça, de me donner
les moyens réussir la dedans et que, et que ouais
j'ai fait plein de trucs différents
dont plein de trucs pourris, des fois vous m'avez soutenu
des fois vous m'avez dit : "Oh attention Lucas la tu vas dans une branche c'est un peu de la merde   !"
C'était une putain d'aventure YouTube et ça continue
Heu, 5 ans après, presque 6 ans
en Mars ça fera 6 ans que la chaîne existe
C'est juste incroyable donc voilà je voulais vous remercier
je trouve que sept millions d'abonnés c'était une bonne occasion pour faire cette vidéo
Merci ! d'être si nombreux à suivre les vidéos !
En plus j'ai l'impression que les vidéos vous plaisent beaucoup plus qu'avant
Il y a de plus en plus de gens qui ont mon âge
qui ont 20 piges et tout qui regardent les vidéos et ça me fait super plaisir !
que mon délire vous plaise.
On fait plus de la merde que jamais
Cf les vidéos Pokémon
"Pokémon, rien ne nous arrêtera notre amitié triomphera
Mais c'est ça qu'on aime, c'est ça qu'on veut
donc merci, merci et encore merci puis on se retrouve pour les 8 millions
Aller à très vite dans une prochaine vidéo
Merci d'avoir regardé, j’espère que ça vous aura un petit
peu ému, que vous avez pas versez une petite larme
non plus, parce qu'après je me sentirais coupable.
Si vous avez versé une petite larme, j'espère juste
que c'est parce que vous avez été tellement mal à l'aise
devant les anciennes vidéos que les larmes ont coulé.
Ciao tout le monde ! Peace !